what's up everybody and welcome back to
the verzi effect podcast show my name is
Paul verzi and today is Thursday january
twenty 8 2016 and you guys are listening
to episode 243 um I have a very special
episode this week got a very funny
comedian great guests for the show so
before I do that because we're going to
sit and talk about a bunch of stuff I
just want to get to the sponsors as is
always the versi effect podcast is
sponsored by gonzo fame com go to gonzo
fame com for the best most in-depth
interviews with your favorite comedians
of today um Dave Gavriel they're funny
up and coming comedian in Chicago runs a
great website has got really funny
comedians and as a matter of fact my
guest today has been one of the people
he's interviewed also guys like Hannibal
Buress Doug Stanhope the list just goes
on I had a great time with him and it's
a really really good website if you just
want to hear about comedians that you
either know and are established or up
and coming comedians so check that out
gonzo fame calm and as always support
all things comedy go to all things
comedy com that's where the versi effect
podcast resides and they also did my
album all things records and my guest is
also part of all things comedy so let's
get into that also follow all things
comedy at on twitter at all things
comedy now my guest today is a is a
friend of mine he's been on the show
before I've been on his show many times
he also resides in Westchester with two
children as do I joe Matarese is on the
verge effect and we were doing we're
doing this one through skype so he is
sitting in his home his beautiful home
their inner shell New York I don't know
do you tell people Joe you live there
yeah that all right that's all right no
you don't that at that out all right so
what's going on little it's a it's going
to be funny being on the verge effect
but I have a microphone that's going to
sound different than yours which it'll
probably sound better to your listeners
but know that that's good do you even
want to tell your listeners what tell
others what that I'm basically recording
your podcast right
and sells over so we can do it this way
yeah so what we're doing is I've never
done a podcast actually I've done skype
podcast with Joe before but it's been
through his soundboard um but since
today up we're doing mine we decided
instead of him driving up cuz he's got
to go down towards the city later so we
figured out you know what I'll just do
it like I'm doing yours but we're gonna
do with the verzi effects style and then
you just send me the sound and I'll put
it in so this is how we're doing it yeah
basically people don't know that about
Westchester but it's so [ __ ] big that
just because you and I both live in
Westchester it doesn't mean we're near
each other you're like 45 minutes from
my house yeah like other people like if
they live in the same county it's like
eight blocks and they could be you know
I'll be right over Paul yes yeah see you
know that we're a good 45 we're a good
45 minutes of the way with no traffic
and I want to tell your listeners right
at the top I am completely mentally
fried and I hope I hope I can deliver in
this podcast I had some writing gig pull
I had a rug glad you I glad you wanted
to come on at this one [ __ ] yeah I
love that hey dude let's do a podcast
and again no doubt listen by the way
dude I got nothing that's true do got
nothing yeah I don't know if you're like
me you and I once in a while get these
like writing gigs where we have to write
like roast and stuff you and I have done
him together where you and I teamed up
to write roast jokes I remember well the
sum sum guide you know Marshall child no
I don't know her he owns the Laughing
Skull in Atlanta and he started this
dislike corporate kind of thing where
he's higher I don't know you would say
hiring maybe he goes out and does the
Murray has other comedians doing but
does his corporate roasts where you go
in and you roast all these people that
work at some corporation and he sends
everybody that that I guess agrees to
get roasted at the company has to answer
this like 57 question question ear that
he sends them and then he has all their
questions and he sends them to you as
the writer and says write me jokes on
all these guys questions dude
57 question 13 different people it would
take like a good it almost takes an hour
just to read their answers you know
what's funny about that and it's
probably somebody getting roasted who's
not famous right no it's people that
work at this corporation it's all
corporate people so their questions when
they answer they'll be like what is your
dream day and they're like spending the
day with my children and my wife that I
love that's what I mean when you go when
that my whole point of asking a question
is when you so many like people think
it's like a great idea to roast a friend
or two like roast but like and I never
even understood like when comedians that
aren't famous want to get roasted it's
like I'm not gonna try to be a dick and
say nobody cares but it's like you know
a roast should be you could just pick
somebody out and just destroy them
without never having to meet them you
know like if somebody said hey Jill
write some roast jokes on you know
Taylor Swift you would just be able to
just like listen to a couple of songs no
she isn't crusher right just at with
your comedic stuff about I get it but
listen money's money corporate gigs
recorded corporate gigs and people think
could be funny so roast a friend in
[ __ ] accounting I think his
questionnaire move is a good idea though
like if it was just roast them it would
be hard but because there's these
questions and and you can just slam them
with that the funny thing is I realized
as I'm writing I'm like these sound like
how i would say him now some other guys
gonna do it and it's just it's not gonna
be me like some of the ones i just raw I
got to give you an example here let me
let me pull up the file if I could just
look let's think of who I was like oh
well well one guy was obviously gay it
was pretty funny let me see if I can
find him what's the gay guy the gay guy
I'm like well as funny cuz i'm reading
is his answers to certain questions and
in my head I'm going well he's gotta be
gay he's definitely I'm going he's gotta
be gay I'm just thinking that and then I
get to one of the answers and it's like
I got fired cuz I was gay and I was like
I know it it was just because like well
do one of his uh his hobbies one of them
had said but
would love when guys in the bed one of
them was like what's what sports did you
what were your hobbies as a kid and it
said playing baseball and gardening I
was like that's all our he's he's gay
and like that was one of my jokes that
like all the other kids are out there
you know going hey batter batter batter
hey batter batter I go he's sitting
there over in right field going would
you look at all these dandelions geez
this place needs to be fertilized it's
disgraceful that's one of my jobs that
I'm just like it was it was a fun little
thing but if it dude if I don't think I
could ever be a writer like have that be
my job because my brain is so exhausted
from doing this and it was just three
days I'm like could you imagine if that
was your job you were a writer for Conan
now you had to just show you've
submitted for those jobs though right
firestop I did it yeah back in the day I
remember I submitted for a couple of
late night shows and it was just one of
those things where my manager was
sending me stuff saying hey they're
looking for people and I even like
before like a while before Colbert got
the gig they were like hey Colbert's
looking for people but I gotta tell you
man when I wrote for that dumb I was in
a writers room just a couple of days for
that iol original show and although I
was with friends and had fun I remember
just sitting there and I remember just
being like wow man even when you make
good money and you're writing for a show
that's either popular or whatever it
really is like that nine to five do like
I'm a comic that's just not built for it
I'm just really not like I need that you
know for me work is going to the airport
and dealing with the travel to get to my
hotel to do my gig like that's other
than that like sitting in a room like in
the first hours fun cuz you like know
what about this what about that and then
all of a sudden people like art we're
gonna get lunch and we got to get back
in the office it's like [ __ ] this dude
yeah you know as a comedian your natural
tendency is to not come back from lunch
but that's just if you don't want to
come back from lunch you comedy was the
correct choice as your career yeah yeah
and and I always and I don't want to be
disrespectful or insensitive to people
with day jobs but the whole idea of
getting an hour for lunch or you get in
trouble to me is [ __ ] crazy like it's
just it's like it's just they're such a
just it just seems very much like I
don't know like it like you're like
you're caged like yes [ __ ] you know and
I think cuz we have wives and kids
something can trick you where you cuz
let's face it i mean i could give you a
number out there for your listeners if a
guy gets a starting writing monologue
writer for say Conan or Jimmy Fallon or
something like that it's over three
thousand dollars a week it might be for
forty five hundred dollars a week so you
get that number in your head I
immediately multiply it by how many
weeks are in a year instantly and I'm
like wow that's that's good money Wow I
wouldn't have to worry about my mortgage
oh my god yeah but then all of a sudden
I guess I'm finally maybe I'm finally at
a good point my career because I'm
finally able to go I didn't I didn't get
into this for a [ __ ] job that a job
like where I have to go in at the same
exact time every day yesterday I asked
my manager I go what are the hours he's
like I don't know you probably get in at
nine and you're done at seven I'm like
Jesus Christ you imagine using your
brain to write and then you got to write
about 50 jokes 6075 jokes in a day yet
no you know what it comes down to two
it's that it's I think people that are
really serious about the art don't get
into it for the money and I think when
you don't get into comedy for the money
it's easier to say no if you get into
comedy for the money then the art is
second right you know like and if the
art is second then sure yeah let me get
a show let me write I don't care I got
into this to make money and that's very
rare I don't think anybody in their
right mind goes I'm gonna start doing
stand-up because I wanted for the money
you know i mean i think that the money
is a byproduct of getting great and
getting better at it so no but I'm with
you a hundred percent and the last thing
is the benefit of of writing your jokes
when you're coming
median is to get up and perform them and
and and that feeling we get when they
work is like an amazing euphoric feeling
i just spent three days right in these
and some other person who I don't even
know it's gonna go do them and there's
no way he's gonna be able to like what I
just said to you I can't imagine some
other guy saying that funny I don't I
don't know why oh you mean that with the
gay guy yeah like I said you gotta you
gotta you gotta I want a video I want to
see that I want to see whoever's gonna
do it do it i mean i just spent I spent
14 hours like that doesn't sound like my
brother goes that's not a lot of time I
go do when you're a comedian that has
his own podcast you're going on Palmers
these podcasts to then you're going on
RD Laing spot cast and then you went on
nick de Paula I mean you've got two kids
I got two kids I've been on like nine
pockets i had to do morning radio this
morning to either do some phoner to
promote some gig in Ridgefield
Connecticut tomorrow night I'm like oh
by the way do you know where you're
gonna be a Ridgefield Connecticut is
five minutes from my house is it really
yeah that ridgefield playhouse is like
literally five minutes like you're gonna
be four miles from my house tomorrow
night I was actually gonna do that gig
with Bobby Kelly and I got changed I
when I went on I went on a tour it was
when we did the midwest tour with burr
and Bartnik and i wanted to do the
ridgefield playhouse but i heard it's
awesome and it's literally because you
know when you make a right out of my
when you make a right out of where i'm
living at like I'm a few miles from the
Connecticut border by the bull and you
make a right and you're there no the
poles on the top i'm at the bottom on
the bottom oh I've been to the
ridgefield playhouse a couple times I've
opened for already lying there twice
it's a mouth the place is beautiful oh
is it yeah i'm looking forward to doing
that sometime but that's funny i'm
actually i'll be what really honest on
your podcast I've been doing this lately
I just burned bridges for myself on
people's podcasts yeah I just don't care
but I got some really shitty deal on
this ridgefield playhouse gig right some
some comic book me and I didn't know it
was the ridgefield playhouse when he
booked me he just calls me and goes it's
a theater in Connecticut I'm like all
right and he gives me a money I'm out
okay I'll take it then like two weeks
later he
sends me the flyer for the show and he
and he has a title for the show he's
calling it three got three of Dave's
favorites because any picked three
comedians that evolved on Letterman now
already he never told me that when he
booked me I'm like you now your theme in
it I didn't okay it's got a theme and
then I see ridgefield playhouse and i go
dude I've been trying to do my own show
at the ridgefield playhouse why didn't
you tell me that when you booked me now
I can't go do it myself oh boy and then
he's like oh he's like can you can you
do can you do a lot of promo for the gig
can you go on podcast social media
bulova I go what what do i get if like
we do well and he goes dude I'm gonna
I'm gonna throw some incentive in for
you I sort of got he goes if you can
sell out 500 seats i'll give you an
extra hundred dollars I swear to god
that's the number he says I could dude
do you know how much a comedian makes if
he can sell out 500 seats in the theater
what I'll give you a guess and this is
like a logo not like a bill burr and RD
Laing like this is just like not a guy
like me or you Paul how much how much
would you expect to make if you sold out
500 seats what would you expect how much
would be your total take for the game oh
man that's a hard thing to say cuz it
depends what's what's the price at the
door and all that [ __ ] you know well you
we can guess you and I we probably what
do we charge 25 to 30 that's what what
that's the most we could probably charge
and people would pay it they're not
paying 50 to see you and I it's just
it's a fact I mean I'm not at a level
where I'm gonna go into a theater and
pack it out for fifty bucks yet so no
that's what I'm saying so say we went we
make the ticket $25 let's do them like
that was my joke to my agent I go do
they not know comedians know how to do
math I can do math I have a calculator
on my iPhone $25 a ticket times right x
500 right ten dollars of tickets 5,000
yeah $20 a tickets 10,000 well maybe
this person doesn't understand though I
guess it sounds like the person doesn't
understand he's a comedian but this is
what he didn't understand I go dude for
a hundred dollars
one of the comedians on the show yes
he's hosting it he goes I go dude for a
hundred dollars I don't want to be a
dick I go I can't go anywhere and
promote that do you understand a
comedian has other gigs so if i go and
promote the ridgefield playhouse that if
i sell out i get a extra hundred now
they're not going to come to my show
februari 13th that is the one that i am
making a lot of money if they come to do
you see how it's like it's a juggling
act like why i'm on your pocket right
now is I'm promoting a theater that I'm
doing in haddon township new jersey on
februari 13th like that's why I'm here
that's the one that they're not giving
me a hundred dollars ah just so people
know joe Matarese like he gets to this
honest point where you bring it out of
me Paul no you are one of these guys
i've never seen anything you've already
said this on your pod on i have I yeah
where else where I'll say some honest
about my wife and how I want to [ __ ] a
friend or something like that on
apologist like no but even at um we
might have talked about on your podcast
but excuse me like you'll be at a show
and like the owner and Booker will be
standing in the room and you'll be like
why is it who would like something like
I don't do that anymore I think for
years I did that for you oh you don't
stop that no no that's when you and I
talked about anti well I take
antidepressants I don't even know what
you call what you take but it made me
not do that anymore I don't overly
worried you don't worry about what's
going on no I used to I used too bad i
would change the sound the lights
through there were times where I'd asked
for a ladder a ladder what comedian goes
can you get me a ladder so we can angle
a light a little differently like that
takes you don't work at those places and
no they would get pissed oh boy yeah so
basically that gig you know if i sold it
out should probably pay eight to ten
thousand dollars that's what a comedian
should probably walk away with just no
comedians out there if they listen to
the verzi effect you sell out 500 seats
at $25 a ticket you should probably make
eighty percent ticket
rice you know you should definitely be
making more than one hundred a hundred
bonus like even comedy clubs will give
you 500 for a but-for for a sellout
they'll throw you usually so did you
guys did you guys sell out the Playhouse
is it sold out oh no this was hilarious
he contacts me and he goes uh yeah the
ticket ticket sales are low I'm like no
[ __ ] kidding dude I'm not promoting
this anywhere this is a secret you're
lucky I'm saying it on the verge effect
and and then I said well this is the
part that sucks for me what if I want to
go do the ridgefield playhouse in a
couple years and they're gonna remember
that we didn't sell tickets tonight and
who they gonna blame they're gonna think
I'm not a drawl they're not gonna know
that guy gave me a shitty deal they're
not gonna know that right right I'm
[ __ ] I gotta tell them when i get to
the theater listen there's 80 people
here because there was a hundred dollar
bonus that's funny you get there you
just start preface in like you just you
preface the night by like hey listen
it's bad not because of me yeah that's
me moody McCarthy and Adrian ah pallucci
and Adrian texted me too and she's like
is he asking you to promote like crazy
he's mad at me he said he's mad at the
theater sweet it's moody and Adrian
Adrian was texting me that Adrian a
pallucci well but moody's don't want to
put it together no no no no no no way no
no moody's the greatest that's where the
three comedians on it there's a fourth
comedian who's hosting it I'm not gonna
say his name oh ok but cuz i was gonna
say moody's the greatest know is the
best Moody's low-key yeah yeah okay so
you moody and Adrian that's a great
lineup you guys are on the show and
there's another comedian who booked it
and put it together and he's the one
hosting it and he's the one having you
guys you know he's only given the bed
incentive and he's the one haven't you
guys go crazy to promote it yeah all he
had to do is pay us a normal amount and
he should have known he could have
called us in advance saying I'm gonna
put the three you guys together for this
Letterman thing i'm gonna say it's
dave's favorites i'm this is what he
should have said at the beginning before
even found the place and i'm gonna bring
it into the ridgefield playhouse what
kind of deal you think we should make
with them he should have been out in the
open and I would have said as for this
and then asked here's the next stage if
you sell 300 seats you get this
if you get 400 seats you get this and a
sellout you get the you know you get a
big you get a big kick back right make
that deal then I'm we're on social media
i'm plugging it everywhere i'm gonna
drive to radio stations he wanted me to
drive to New even the new radio I got
dude hundred up that'll cost me a
hundred dollars in gas what are you
talking about there's no way unless you
gave me an insane flat fee I just don't
understand how somebody could say here's
what i'll give you another hundred like
that's so insulting that it tells me
that the person doesn't know though yeah
he doesn't he does not i mean like i
don't think i don't think it's not mean
and cheap he's clue no that's what i'm
saying i don't think it sounds like to
me the guy you're talking about just
doesn't know like I mean to say to a
comedian here's what I'll do for you if
we sell it out with 500 i'll give you an
extra hundred like anybody else would
just hang up the [ __ ] phone no i
actually believe the i believe this guy
that he didn't know and that they're not
gonna give him much money for a sell out
like he didn't know that the you know
that he should have asked for more he
hasn't yeah i do believe that well what
his letterman think I mean he's the one
who says you guys are his favorite is
let I mean if let him do anything he's
in Connecticut that would be nor if norm
McDonald was on the gig that would be as
opening five minutes oh yeah and even
know Dave I'd me yeah yeah that's that's
that's hilarious thousands favorite it
took me seven years to get a rebooking
so wait the theater this so that's the
theater seats I thought that I thought
it was bigger than 500 it's only a five
hundred seater I think it's 500 550
maybe oh so it must look small then it's
like it's intimate but it doesn't though
it steered it has two tiers it's very
nice it's almost have you been it's five
minutes from your house it almost looks
like you're you're not at a theater your
it looks like they built it onto a
school or something it's ah ok and that
towns really nice Richfield no that's
that's that's we go there a lot so yeah
that's definition of the wrong gig
that's hilarious I nice I need the
februari 13th Ritz theater at the head
and
uh and haddon township new jersey that's
the one I'm really I already so Matarese
calm for tickets for that that's the one
I gotta sell out yeah I'll so yeah let's
talk about that one which which one is
that now it's only 350 seats and I had
an article come out today in my in the
pit newspaper that is big down in South
Jersey where I grew up and hopefully
that helps sell it out and this is
februari 13th yeah our februari 13th a
few guys any of my listeners are in that
area make sure you go down and see Jojo
is hilarious you'll have a great time
the last time I was in South Jersey
under the last time I was down that way
me you and burr had arguably I mean in
my opinion you know I've been fortunate
enough to be involved in some pretty
amazing and epic shows you know but I
gotta tell you man this is this was
right up there that Wells Fargo is right
up there with in my opinion it was I
actually got to be honest I had more fun
at wells fargo than i did at the garden
only because there were there were
definitely like the garden started going
off great and then there was some sound
issues but dude wells fargo we had up
what a night that was 10,000 plus i was
insane it was my first time going to a
cigar bar also and smoking a cigar and
drinking a little bourbon and with you
and Bill and Bill's manager that was
such and then we went got cheesesteaks
afterwards like i'ma I'm at that you're
still a younger comedian than me so you
like you're like the gig the gig and I'm
like talking about what we did after it
like that know what we did after was
great that that cigar bar was really
nice i've totally forgot that we were on
a mission to get a cheesesteak and we
should i remember my stomach being a
mess after that well I remember list I
actually somebody tell somebody I'm
friends with texted me said burr talked
about you on his podcasts about the
wells fargo show so I went and listened
and I don't even remember this he said
that you and I were like falling down
drunk walking into the cheesesteak place
and we were talking loud about people
and he was like getting embarrassing and
saying that he was sober I'm like I
don't remember him haven't let that we
drink more than him yeah no I think he
stopped drinking or me and you had a
couple of more you know typical married
guys trying to get in the last licks you
know and
uh yes I me and you had a little more
but I think what we were doing is it was
just filled with all these [ __ ]
animals and there it was a shitshow it
was like two o'clock in the morning
there was a huge line I think somebody
had their kid in there like it was just
a mess and me and you were like clearly
going like look at this guy like this
guy and there was a guy being really
loud and Bill was like dude you guys
gotta shut up me I don't want to get you
know you guys were gonna get our asses
kicked butt no he did talk about you
dude you killed that night I remember
you were really nice when you got on
stage and you addressed me killing on
stage and then you [ __ ] killed and
then bill came up and killed and it was
just like and the funny thing was you
know the whole feel I have like I feel
like I have a connection with philly now
because of that because you know
everybody was kind of like wow this is
philly it's in an arena there's over
10,000 people for a comedy show it
started almost 40 minutes late and those
people in that building could not have
been it was almost like could you
imagine like going into philly 10,000
people and when you're in a setup they
were quiet as can be it was amazing dude
it was [ __ ] amazing I still remember
you and I were backstage waiting yeah
well and and you made me write down like
a like an exact script how I was going
to be the voice of God backstage and
introduced the beginning of the show and
everything he said was like dead on yeah
because and you know why I did that
because we would go to shows on the road
me lawhead Bartnik bill and all of these
beautiful theaters we go hey uh do you
guys have somebody to announce and I
would never go up first it would be
usually lawhead and what I'd love to do
it because he always liked lauds dream
job was to be the guy at basketball
games being like good evening or like
call a basketball game so I'll do that
to all do lawhead would come out I swear
to god he took it so seriously Joe he
really good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the Chicago theater I are
proud to present bill burr and then he
and then they would all [ __ ] it I'm
doing it exactly like him and they would
all laughing and he would go like you
would be like uh bill brought up you
know some of his favorite comics and
friends here tonight and blah blah blah
he'd be like first and he would just
[ __ ] give you this
like he's blah blah blah listener or he
would announce himself so he'd be like
he's known as one of the they worked in
a tailgate Rose Bowl tailgate legends
keep it going for Jason lot he would do
this whole thing and it would be [ __ ]
amazing right he would do it for himself
so then we would go to gigs where like
if somebody didn't want to do that some
like [ __ ] stage guy would just be
like you know all right guys your first
guy coming out and it was just [ __ ]
sucked so I I learned so when we were
out there and Wells Fargo didn't have a
guy and you didn't want to go or you
were let you had family you wanted to go
like in the middle to show whatever or
you know you because especially in your
hometown you know going out there so you
were like you were like yeah you know
you go and I was like all right then can
you announce me and you were like yeah
and then I was like all right so this is
what I've learned and it nailed it dude
you nailed it I still remember the
moment i'm trying to think the exact
script that it was something like what
you just said when you were doing
Bartnik where I went ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the Wells Fargo
Center it was like one of those the
wells fargo center to is proud to
present will burn was like they went
like like it was like I said ACDC it was
like so cool and it wasn't too high in
like I don't like when I when a guy goes
on stage and he's like are you guys
reading about it like I don't like that
we know that was better like the
basketball announcer is a great
comparison yes you had a nice medium
where it's not like Bartnik did it at
the garden and it sounded like he was
bringing out Hogan I don't like that no
um but he actually did a good don't know
he'd the way he did it was good he just
had to be loud because it was so big but
the craziest thing about Wells Fargo I
don't know if you remember this I'm sure
you do but you know you kind of stay
more stationary on stage than I do you
know but I I remember being up there and
my kind of stock in the stage going back
and forth like I do and at one point I
just looked up to the right and it was
like three decks like up where the
luxury boxes were and I saw somebody
silhouette in a shadow so far away
yet still paying attention and that's
when I was like this is really cooler
than I thought it would be you you know
you think an arena is gonna be a [ __ ]
show and not be but it really is like if
you get people that are really into
comedy and they just were and I think
that that's a testament to bills crowds
but I mean the cool thing is mia when
bill will share that is one of the great
it's like like I said man that in the
garden but I had more fun because Philly
didn't have any sound issues like you
know it was just it was just amazing
well I loved it and then and your family
was there like I you know like your
family was there like my family was at
the garden like my mom one of the
coolest things was like my mom saying to
me I'm glad you know because my mom was
sick and thank God because of medicine
she's all right but she's like saying
like I'm glad I was alive to see that
like when you do a gig like that like
your mom and dad remember you telling me
before the show you're like yeah my mom
my dad my brother they're all here and
it's just like watching you in the third
tier 2 as it was funny they were in the
third tier they were way up there
hilarious that's hilarious my mom and
dad actually told me this almost like
gave me the chills and like made me tear
up a little they told me they high-fived
each other at the end of my set like it
must have been one of those moments
where they're like please don't [ __ ]
bomb please don't [ __ ] bomb and like
it went well cuz I you know like I five
day that's like right thing I've ever
heard yeah like ma you know cuz I have a
son who's playing sports now and it's
cellar it's like I go to his basketball
game and I'm just like if he makes one
[ __ ] shot my wife and I are gonna
like hug each other for an hour dude I
almost puked before lucas's first tee
ball at bat I swear to god dude when my
son got up for t-ball for the first time
my heart was jacked up I was more
nervous for that than performing and a
gig like it was just like it like a busy
gig like walking it like I had the same
like if you walk into a 500 cedar and
everybody's there to see you I wasn't as
nervous as my son being on deck and the
and the shitty kid before him like hit
you know what I mean and then my son
just goes up and I'm hoping to God he
remembers how to swing it and
keep his eye on the tea and the coach
like you know and it was just like and
then I remember he made contact with his
first swing ever and he was just running
to first and I was so happy so I
couldn't imagine watching your parents
and you know my parents at the garden
watching your child walk out in a
legendary arena in front of tens of
thousands of people and they have to be
funny like you know what i mean so
that's the life we chose i guess but not
with it was awesome it actually there's
there was an article that came out in
the courier-post today to promote my
februari 13th gig and it was referenced
in the article oh that's Austin amazing
article I don't even realize how much
like Rocky is a theme like I I didn't
realize that I'm like the I'm becoming
like the rocky comedian or something and
he connected rocky through the whole
article he had different pictures right
up your alley yeah he had and I and we
sent them all these pictures of me like
on the on the steps you know the rocky
steps and then you know me at at the
phillies stadium and then me eating like
a Geno's steaks like a cheesesteak and
that the whole the whole rocky thing and
I just lost my train of thought but it I
just it was cool because like I said he
referenced it in the article the wells
fargo center thing and it was amazing
and like what you said earlier I feel
like people will remember me and it's
weird they do they don't you go to
Philly and you promote something you
gotta mention that you did that because
they'll go oh I remember that they will
remember and they'll come and see you
because I couldn't imagine what it's
like for you because even for me before
the garden and even after the garden
people are like wow man I heard about
your filly said I heard about the wells
fargo i think so many people heard it
and i'm in new york i mean you you're a
cherry you're a cherry hill kid so I
mean that's like six miles away from
Philly and I couldn't I could only
imagine like you know when I did the
garden I had people like friends and
family and people from high school that
I haven't seen in like seventeen years
and people just go wow I'm at the guard
and good luck and it's just because it's
it's it's it's actually bigger like I
don't think of it like that we don't
think of it like that because
us it's just a gig did you have okay can
I ask you a question did you have an ad
lib at the beginning of your set
anywhere that referenced the connection
of New York and you and where you're
lived or anything about anything yeah
well what i said when i first got on
stage I said this is amazing to be here
at em as I remember my first bit it was
my first laugh I said it's amazing to be
here at msg this is incredible I said
I'm from New York and I said sort of be
at Madison Square Gardens amazing i said
last night i performed for 19 people in
queens at which I did and and that got
like my first left but I definitely
referenced being at the garden and being
being a New Yorker and stuff like that
and one of the coolest things ever was
after my second or third joke hit all of
my jokes hit and I remember after my
third joke this was before the sound
issue ironically but I remember after
the third one I just go oh my god I'm
killing the garden right now I remember
I remember that in my mind and then all
of a sudden there were rumblings of like
sound like like it was a couple things
but I just stayed the course and I told
you the whole thing it was like I was
maneuvering and working and nobody
really knew but the jokes did hit and
and everything worked out but ya know it
was pretty [ __ ] amazing to walk out
on that stage but you know was cool is
when me you and Bill did the sound check
at wells fargo that was the first time
any of us or i don't know about you but
that was the first time for me that was
the first time or i was like oh my god
dude i'm doing a sound check in an arena
in a basketball arena and like just
hearing the sound member i tweeted out
we videoed for like 20 seconds and i
tweeted it out looks cool said something
into the microphone it was so loud here
it's like holy [ __ ] man so that's uh
yeah this is this is definitely cool to
to reminisce about it but so I want it
you know what I'm going to do because
we're 40 minutes in and you have
somewhere to be I'm gonna make this this
is going to be um this is gonna be uh
I'm gonna do two parts of my podcast
okay whatever you want to do this will
be one part with the joe Matarese that
i'll just upload this and and do a
separate one here but i wanted to talk
about a couple of things and everybody
go see Joe februari 13th where is it Joe
exactly it is called the Ritz theater
it's in head in Township New Jersey and
all they have to do to buy tickets to it
and is the saturday before Valentine's
Day so if you're anywhere in that area
or you want to make a trip out of it and
stay overnight with your girlfriend of
your wife there's hotels are cheap down
there you get a hotel for like nothing
come come come and check it out go to
joe Matarese calm and there's a link
there's like two links right on the main
page where you can buy tickets to that
show februari 13th haddon township ritz
theater alright so you know what I'll do
with you here is will tell you you're a
are you uh what would you say on a scale
of one to ten with your NFL football
watching and knowledge where are you at
and that in a one to ten where are you
cuz actually I thought you were less of
a sports guy than you really are you're
more than I think people would think
especially like we've talked NFL I know
you're a big-time Philadelphia Eagles
fan um but where are you at you probably
like out of seven right six or seven NFL
or would you say like a five with
depends on whose podcast him on on Artie
Lange's podcast they always [ __ ] on me
but like I don't know nearly as much but
like Artie's a savant he knows an insane
amount yeah my brother knows an insane
amount my brother makes fun of me like
cuz he'll be like do you have a [ __ ]
TV do you how do you not [ __ ] notice
like I'm like dude I'm sorry the [ __ ]
Philly news doesn't come through in New
York immediately I'd all right I didn't
know our one that Jimmy Rollins got
traded to the Dodgers it took me a
couple days like leave me alone like
yeah ya know some guys are a little like
those fantasy guys are a little that's
even more than me but the NFL is such an
amazing it really is like the NFL like
the amount of women that watch the NFL
like the NFL football is insane and did
you watch the NFC and AFC championship
games yeah watch both games i would i
would say compared to you i'm probably a
six or seven you're probably in a 10 or
not no no a lot more than me I'm not NFL
wise I'm I think I'm good NFL wise but
all around sports like I gotta knock
some points off me because I just know
nothing about hockey so like I can talk
I'm football oh if we're just talking
football yeah I'm probably close to
attend if you're talking NFL except
minus the fantasy I don't do fantasy but
um I don't know dude I think you know
I'll do my official pick obviously next
week before the Super Bowl but a
preliminary pic right here I just how do
you bet against Carolina because of from
top to [ __ ] bottom you can't we were
talking about this last night at the
comic strip because I I this is the show
mine my shitty knowledge I was trying to
say I thought I was making a great point
that's a layer that um Cam Newton
shouldn't have done that crazy died for
the touchdown where he did the flip I go
he's your [ __ ] marquee player you
must be like a and then Vic Henley just
cut right in and he goes man I watched
and play it all burn he goes that guy 66
250 he ain't getting hurt if he goes in
the air and flies and does a flip you're
gonna get hurt if he lands on you but
he's fine and I was just like I didn't
realize I'm such an idiot I didn't know
the guy was 66 bit I actually I actually
argued with that was somebody and I said
he was 66 he's not 66 65 yeah I think I
think he's like 642 something either way
he's gigantic huge and and but here's
the thing Denver's defense is the best
in the league and when they penetrated
the offensive line of the Patriots Tom
Brady's running for his life but Tom
Brady's not mobile if you penetrate Cam
Newton he's gonna find a [ __ ] he's
gonna find the lane and that guy's gonna
run I'm telling you right now I think
that guy could run for 75 100 yards
rushing in this game because he just can
break down a defense I hope not I'm
gonna be honest I would love to see
Peyton Manning's last game ever kind of
go out like Elway you know he's lost
already two Super Bowls in 11 this would
tie him with his brother and it would be
a great exit I gotta be honest I don't
think it's gonna happen I think
Carolina's defense is is slightly under
the Broncos but still insane and I look
cam newton man he could make a throw he
could run you gotta love and I think
Vegas has the odds at like whatever
they're well I think the spread right
now was it you know what I'll tell you
right now with the spread is but i think
i think it's moved up it opened up
for hold on one day it opened it yet
opened at four I'll tell you right now
what it is but um I would my guess right
now what do you say my guess right now
is I'm gonna say a Carolina minus six
what do you think I'm trying to remember
what last year's Super Bowl went off at
do you have any idea Oh point spread on
that it was like for it was it where was
it a pick'em no it wasn't a pic I don't
think it was a pic um I think it was
like a thaw my god was it was getting
yeah I'm so cool it was low if there was
a spread all right here we go right here
NFL odds it is three so the Panthers are
favored by three right now wow I thought
it would be I thought it would be more
just because you know why see that means
that that that means that Denver's d
people think Denver's d could do there d
was insane you know but Brady can't run
Brady runs like he's got [ __ ] in his
pants and this guy is an animal so he
done he runs a lot better than the
Eagles quarterback did Jesus Oh bradford
bradford was if you he might have been
the worst running / quarterbacked in
philly history he was like it was like
he was wearing cement boots I was like I
don't know I didn't like the way he
moved around he ran like he was holding
a microwave and trying to keep it level
whose line is that yours yeah so Larry
that's perfect that is a good perfect
I'm touching that so yes so I like I
mean I like Carolina but it's funny that
it's only three now here's the other
thing that I was talking I got into an
argument with burr about this and I'll
bring this up to you i'm into these i'm
not gonna get into movies now cuz we're
almost a 50 minutes here but um i was
watching there's a documentary on
netflix called champs and it kind of
talks about uh Bernard Hopkins Mike
Tyson and all this stuff and then
there's clips things that I haven't seen
of Mike Tyson like from 17 to 20 years
old when he was training up in the
Catskills under custom Otto and he was
such an absolute like Joe do you like
the YouTube clips of him knocking people
apple and he was like training to being
the Olympics he was knocking guys that
were 65
66 out cold feet coming off the canvas
so fast so then there's a youtube clip
of what they would think would happen if
he fought ollie right now i'll leave
what fraser three times Frazier only
beat him once but Tyson and Frasier
Frasier from Philly uh they're built the
same but Tyson was so much faster so my
initial thing was this Ali's the
greatest of all time I I truly believe
that and I felt as though he's a smarter
fighter than Tyson and he would
frustrate Tyson and once it went on past
the fourth or fifth round he would have
his number and beat him kind of the way
Vander Holyfield did but I changed my
tune I think from 87 88 in his prime
when he would come out and just throw
hay makers that were so fast and nuts I
think he would have caught Ali and
knocked him out early I think if they
fought 10 times Hollywood beat him 8 but
i do think Tyson would catch him and
knock him out Tyson was it do you
remember watching Tyson when you were
you you got to remember those
pay-per-views that went 30 30 seconds of
course I did that's right in my right
when i was starting stand up probably i
like an 18 19 year-old i can remember i
think i was in in the caribbean I
remember doing some gig when he when he
fought Michael Spinks that 96-90 one
second yeah and that one was hilarious
and I I thank God I think because we
were comedians we didn't have to pay
like thirty dollars i get into the bar
to watch the game they like let us come
in for free and it was just funny
watching i used to love when Tyson would
get really close to a guy and then throw
that uppercut the guy that you couldn't
see him even throw it you just like why
the guy fall down and then they'd slow
it down there like oh he [ __ ] him up
he just swung with an uppercut that was
invisible it was so fast and that's the
thing some big guy would just slow down
and drop and it would look like he got
shot from somebody in the upper deck
yeah they would be fighting a guy would
just go limp dude but you gotta watch
there's one thing and for anybody that
likes like documentaries or sports it's
on netflix it's called champs and
there's a clip of him just hitting the
bag and you're going oh my
sky it was a killing machine it was one
of the most insane things I've ever seen
and his first title fight he went up
against this dude who was like 65
gigantic the guy had the belt and in no
time he was just knocking him around the
Rick like it was like he was a pinball
it was unbelievable dude but but also I
liked about Tyson is he was fun to
listen to after a fight like a lot of
these athletes now they're just not no
one's exciting you know when they're
just talking like I'm those are always
my favorite athletes like John McEnroe
[ __ ] losing his [ __ ] I used to love
watching [ __ ] light and Tyson I still
remember do you remember i'm sure i
think which fight it was they
interviewed him afterwards and he just
goes he was making little woman noises
indeed i was going oh oh every time I
snapped one of his webs I still remember
that i love i loved one he goes i broke
my back and and uh and jim gray goes
what like you mean like he goes yeah my
speech spinal and like so he was he
geograph somebody goes you mean like in
the vertebrae like something happy good
Mike it was spinal but dude he was
basically fighting with a crack in his
spine and he was just like but no you're
that's a really good point that you say
that because when i was watching the
documentary nobody talked as candidly as
honest as tyson even after like even
when he told what's his name when he
said this is in my heart anymore he goes
dismember he was just like he lost for
like the third time in a row was at the
end of his career and he goes listen he
goes I'm fighting for a paycheck this
isn't in my heart anymore i'm done but
it was just like not a lot of guys would
say that a lot of guys would just be
like ah you know and just move on but he
was just one of those guys that had that
vulnerability um dear yeah you know what
i mean and and like I heard in his
one-man show which did really good the
one-man show that he was doing in vegas
for a while people said it was amazing
where he was talking about how he's like
listen I should be in jail for a lot of
things but rape is not one of them and
he was just talking about and even like
he was canned in an interview where he
was like yeah I did three years as an
innocent man and I really was and he
just has that honest vulnerability we're
like he even says he goes dude I was a
savage i did i'm awful things like he
really shouldn't call him so he's like I
I grew up in a place where nobody should
see you grow up and I did awful thing
I feel like that guy is a type of person
that would like admit it you know like
he's just that crazy for you know what I
mean and he was just like you know I
didn't do it but no I like what you said
about that joke cuz i was thinkin about
that not too many guys you see a lot of
great people and great athletes they're
like robots in the interview you know
like like a-rod yeah you know it gave me
a good pitch and we're just happy to get
this one and they always kind of say
[ __ ] like that or it's like you know
even as great as Jeter was Jeter never
gave you I like the guys that gave you
like that nutty kind of real thing and
you're like wow this is a real Duke now
what you got to compare it to stand up
comedy it's the same way comedians we if
you get a little crazy now you're like
there's people tweeting oh my god it
made me uncomfortable yeah like there
there wouldn't we grew up in a time
where like funk enjoyment who was it as
its own name yet Joe Namath is drunk on
Monday Night Football saying he wants to
make out with the girl I was at that
game you don't see that [ __ ] everybody's
to protected you don't see the crazy
like person doing some crazy [ __ ] right
on TV like you said like Tyson I'm
trying to think who else is just like
[ __ ] like Isis Mike Tyson said in the
conference it was in the documentary he
said in a press conference when he
completely had a meltdown in losses
should he grabbed his dick pointed at
the guy I said I'm gonna [ __ ] you in the
ass until you love me [ __ ] he said
that it yeah he's sounding to [ __ ] you
in the ass white boy and he said I'll
fight you know on that you know good
thing he said I'm gonna I want to eat
his children um and like I mean those
were the ones that went like a little
overboard like Kanye West's doing that
now where I saw a tweet where Kanye West
said he's the greatest to ever
contribute to the music but he said he's
literally the greatest to ever create
music like he's like on a level of that
he said you know he also said what's
that thing burst said in his bit he
burst said in his joke he said his one
regret is that he'll never be able to
see himself perform live he said that
he's the greatest he's better than the
boe what'd he say he said I said he's
the greatest to ever create music like
when it gets to that level I don't mean
that I just mean a guy who's like yeah
you know whatever I [ __ ] up I thought
I could do this stupid like I like guys
like that
you know the optically the vulnerable
honesty but going back to what I said I
watched a clip of Ali throwing his hands
he's the only heavyweight that I've ever
seen throw like a lightweight that's how
fast it was that fight would have been
fascinating here's what I would love to
see if I had a time machine taking Tyson
in 87 or 88 in a time machine to Ali's
prime and letting those two just go at
it would be would be unbelievably
fascinated because he I'm urging
everybody whether you listen to my show
or if you listen to fixing Joe do
yourself a favor and YouTube Mike Tyson
knockouts and Mike Tyson in his prime
and just watch this guy throw punches
that it's like dude if it hit me and you
were dead or coma coma just my body
going limp dead yet i was there i
remember that being like thee that was
the hacky I fallen and I can't get up
joke of the mid-80s was about how people
said I'll fight I'll fight tyson if
you're gonna pay me 10 million dollars
like yeah you're not gonna be able to
even [ __ ] count your money cuz you're
gonna be brain dead like that was like
the hacky that was the hacky joke every
community what year did you start doing
stand-up 89 like 89 9 what yeah oh you
started in the 80s I started the first
time I ever did a set I did an open mic
in Woodstock New York at a bar in 99 but
I was getting up like once barely once
every two you know I mean barely getting
up so I gotta go I haven't started going
hard probably until like 03 is when I
kind of started to go like you know hard
so you probably 13 years as a pro but um
yeah man I didn't realize you started in
the 80s so you must have saw a lot of
guys you must have saw a lot of guys in
New York City that moved to LA or you
know stuff like that that just like you
saw every you you you you started almost
in the boom well kinda I'm trying to
remember my if I ever had a Mike Tyson
joke you got me thinking now I think I
everybody had here's what everybody had
in the late 80s just from me watching
like evening at the improv and certain
things there was always an oj joke there
was always a well Jay was in the early
90s but there was always an oj joke
there
always a Michael Jackson joke yeah like
if I think of hack jokes that should
never be talked about again I think oj
and Michael Jackson those two just you
cannot touch them anymore I definitely
had something hacky about Tyson and his
voice not matching his body size
something like that yeah I mean you
would have to oh I think it was
something like even Michael Jack's this
I made it doubly hack I said even
Michael Jackson was at home going what
if what a [ __ ] sound like that that's
like the joke Michael Jackson called him
a [ __ ] I did a crush Oh probably yeah I
go his voice is so high only dogs could
hear it something like that oh that's
great school was the first comedy club
you ever did in new york city in new
york city ever your first new york city
comedy show ever mine was new york
comedy club under al Martin which by the
way under the new guy Emilio is amazing
right now it's amazing yeah I like that
place have you seen it yo you say yeah
yeah it's nice I was there last night
was awesome did you hear they open to
comedy club in Yonkers your about that
yeah I'm doing it I'm doing it march i'm
excited at seven minutes from my house
oh that's awesome yeah so uh what the
hell did you just ask me first first
comedy club in New York ever I think I
did one of those bringer shows like were
you bring people well no that's what I
did I had to bring three people to new
york comedy club I think this I didn't
even live in New York that's what was
funny true how am i s'posed I had to
like get people from cherry hill to come
to New York I think I did I think I did
stand-up New York with just comedians
were my bringers I brought three
comedians and paid their covers and then
the first time I did like a bigger show
was like those bringer shows at
carolines where they would videotape you
and I brought all my cherry hill friends
and family made them come all the way up
this is classic you just made me
remember this you know that shell game
they play on the streets in New York yes
like we call art the three-card Monte
yeah my brother being such a suburb kid
he will let's see if I was 24 he's nine
years younger I mean he was like a
teenager and he came with my parents
and I think they asked him to go put
money in the meter and when he went out
there they were playing three-card Monte
and he would just stand in watching this
shows you in New York and the guy says
to my brother out of nowhere he just
looks back and goes which one do you
think it's under and he's like I'm not
playing i'm not playing God just guess
I'll let you guess I'm not gonna you
know you don't have to play just guess
and my brother goes there that one the
second one the guy goes you're right
you're right you win you win and he's
like what do you mean I'm not playing
you win all you have to do is put money
down and then you win and he had my
[ __ ] wallet cuz I gave him I just
gave him my wallet I go go put money in
the meter the greats who takes all the
cash out of my wall throws it down on
the Monte I think like 50 bucks and the
guy just grabs the 50 they grabbed they
had like a box set up with the game on
it and they just grabbed the Box grab my
money and just [ __ ] run down the
street take home my brother was like you
I lost it I lost your 50 bucks and even
I hadn't been on stage yet i'm doing a
bringer and i'm down 50 that i remember
yeah I remember I did a three person you
had to bring three people that guy Steve
errands and I told people that you know
they told me I'd go on at nine I end up
going on at 11 and it was they would all
[ __ ] you great set yeah I'm gonna
have my casting people look at him and
watch my set just [ __ ] it you know I
[ __ ] dropped out of college because
they called it an industry night and uh
yeah god I swear to god like I wrote a
letter to the professor saying that like
yeah keep this maybe you'll see me on
[ __ ] what a SNL or some [ __ ] you know
you man SNL I'm not doing this and I
dropped out of college um but anyways so
so joe Matarese this week at the Ritz
theater that's not this week it's
februari 13 this hunk of this week was
the ridgefield thing don't don't come to
that I'm anxious tongue don't come tell
you don't come that's tomorrow night
don't worry 13th um check them out is
there anything else you got going on
dude what's what's uh what's going on
well the fixing Joe podcast is at this
situation here it's fine I've been
talking to these advertisers I'll tell
you this off the
but I had this idea it's like I started
thinking about a comedian like an
athlete Mike Holcomb warned you know
we're sponsored on our podcasts why
can't I be sponsored like like my way to
rate well like I started thinking about
this I'm like if a company wants to
advertise on my podcast I'm like I do a
lot I'm on a lot of other guys podcast 2
i'm like like I'm going to Artie Lange's
podcast after I had you know stop this
one with you is I started thinking I'm
like if this company wants to advertise
when when you go onto another podcast
why can't already go Joe what are your
plugs and I go my plugs and then I say
the I do the 22nd commercial right there
and you know like cover me and then I go
to the advertiser on the phone I go I'll
shoot I'll do a joke about it in my
stand-up I'll video it I'll throw it on
are you gonna move your advertisers to
other shows yeah I couldn't you cuz they
go well what are your numbers and I
wanted to go well technically if I'm
saying in on Artie's versys mine nicht
Apollo's and Anthony kumi is I got high
numbers I could see you on Artie's and
already go and show you thirsty why it's
funny you ask when i get part yeah I
drank gatorade oh i wish i was comparing
it to Pauly and rocky though remember in
Paulie and rocky the whole movies like I
got an idea can I use your name and he
just starts figuring out ways you know
he puts that he gets him the road but he
puts like the [ __ ] billboard on the
back of Rocky's Rome he has ways like
there why couldn't we widest F curry get
money you know for all these kids buying
his sneakers why couldn't you and I go
on here we're opening for bill burr in
front of 12,000 people why can't I be
wearing something from [ __ ] Hugo Boss
that they gave me that I go like this
cuz we don't drop 35 points a night all
over the country against great NBA
professional but one thing I'm learning
about advertising this is what I'm
learning cuz i've been reading a lot
about it i've been talking to people
that are in this industry you just lower
the numbers oh yeah okay he's on every
TV show he gets multi-million dollars
there's no reason why you and I can't
get a you know a thousand dollars to
talk about it you know where he's
getting a million dollars why
can't we get a thousand why can't we hit
a lot of singles that's the way I look
at it that's hilarious do you disagree
with me um yeah I mean listen I'm not
gonna call you're delusional is that
delusional I'm not gonna call you
delusional because I understand what
you're saying but I just think it's it's
because of the greater the masses it
really what it comes down to is the
numbers and the thing is Steph Curry's
doing something exceptional in front of
20,000 people almost night in and night
out now I would agree with you just went
on a tour with bill burr how many people
know all this how many people saw you in
three months ah use this a lot 200,000
people yeah probably a couple maybe you
know ya a hundred thousand people know I
hear what you're saying on a lower scale
you should definitely do it but I'm
sponsored by a bourbon that's throwing
you some money and you're talking about
that bourbon in your set why okay what
about cigars there you go but there it's
got to be something connected to you
that's what they say these advertisers
they go it's easy for me to sell a
company if it makes sense that you're
advertising it now if you mr. cigar it
makes total sense no it does I that I
definitely one hundred percent agree
with you I agree we'll send you a box of
them you love them and you're talking
about him on every podcast sit I'm
calling davit off right now and I'm
gonna tell them that I've been going at
their davit off Nicaraguan hard I got
people sending me pictures on Twitter
saying I just tried that davit off
Nicaraguan you love and I love it why
not get money for that that's what I'm
saying that's exactly what I'm saying
community absolutely right it's like
that guy wanted to give us a hundred
dollars to sell out a theater it's like
what what why I'll be the comedian that
is good at math I'll give you here's the
numbers I'm going on stage this many
times so I got an incentive for you
here's what I got for you alright next
time we work together if you bring 30
people I could get a t-shirt for you I
got 11 bucks i'll give you again i love
how he's like here I got an incentive
for you like you're gonna be like oh my
god maybe I'll get out of you another
couple grand do go read the book Rich
Dad Poor Dad have you heard of this book
I know it do you have trouble reading no
like you said I get tired no I all I
read his sports read this I read by the
audiobook and my son's books for school
it's changing my life I'm reading this
book right now rich dad poor dad it's
about this Hawaiian guy that grew up he
had a very intellectually a collegian
father who didn't have a lot of money
and one of his friends dads dropped out
of high school and was a multi
multi-millionaire and he's tutoring him
how to make money through his life and
he's comparing advice from the poor dad
who has a good job and went to college
to the poor guy who's a genius and I
read this whole chapter last night where
I was just like made me want to sell my
house when I got done the chapter
because it it was breaking it down in in
pictures he was graphing it how people
think a house is an asset they think
it's a good thing it's an asset and he
broke it all down he's like no a house
is a liability and he was showing that
rich people don't stack up liabilities
they stack up assets I don't know if
this is making any sense now go ahead
he's basically saying that um lower your
liabilities like a house is something
that it keeps breaking gotta keep fixing
it this happened this happened I gotta
fix fix fix money here money their money
here money their mortgages if you're
paying your exact amount of your
mortgage every month you're never
knocking down the principal he's saying
it's not a good investment you're not
you know unless you're paying way over
your mortgage payments every month
you're just paying interest most of the
time then you end up selling the house
just to pay off the mortgage it doesn't
there's no gain and then you go buy
another one and you stick it in and
you're back in the same situation and he
was like showing that smart people
basically uh they lower that and they
they know how to invest their money to
make money and that a house isn't a good
investment i was like jesus [ __ ]
christ he's right because i started
thinking of my house do you ever get
this look like this with your house you
start looking at it and you can see the
things that are starting to go like it
just naturally goes with the weather you
can see you're like our i'm going to
need a whole new roof in about five
years the whole house is going to need
to be painted i can see where it's like
it's going to eventually need it's going
to need it your your kitchen that's new
now
is going to be old or whatever and it's
amazing and you sit there and go the one
of these he said this is why the rich
get richer because they they they they
don't do that [ __ ] they like right
they'll spend their money on the thing
that's gonna make them money they don't
spend it on that thing right what I all
but I think that I think what you're
saying is true but I also think that
that's for people that buy a house that
they really can't afford I feel like
that's for people that overextend
themselves I think if you buy an
affordable house I think if you drive a
practical car and you watch I'm saying
most people don't most people know all
nice stuff right and I ya know that's
true man there's all these books about
how it's funny you brought that up
because somebody was tell me the other
day there's books on how to really
manage money and how to deal with money
and many many people don't people spend
the percentages of money they spend on
their paycheck is opposite of what they
should do you know people get a paycheck
and probably spend seventy percent of it
and you know or eighty percent of it and
if you shouldn't because it goes to I
got paid so now I'm gonna buy shoes I my
car payment my house I'm gonna do this
it's I'm gonna eat out he said most of
us the more money we make the nicer
things we get that's the mistake like oh
I made more now I'm gonna fix my kitchen
oh I made even more now I'm gonna do the
bathrooms you just keep doing this stuff
and was not worried look when you when
you when you hear about Bill Gates and
you hear about Mark Cuban and these guys
what do they always say about those guys
they dress normal they were jeans like
so like Bill Gates said he goes to you
know goes to macy's and just gets a pair
of jeans and and wears a nice sweater
and that's it like it's not you know I
think people I mean that documentary I
was talking about Tyson even if van der
Holyfield everybody calls Tyson dumb for
blowing 300 million Evander Holyfield is
is had to file for chapter evander
holyfield have two hundred million
dollars he had a [ __ ] palace in
Georgia in Atlanta he had a palace it
looked like [ __ ] were like the Roman
Emperor like it looked and he had to get
now he went now it's like this empty
deserted is kind of said they showed
pictures of the pool drained and like
this beautiful she had like this tony
montana staircase on two sides going
down you had this gigantic thing and
it's just i mean they showed mike tyson
walking a white tiger I mean the guy
started buying exotic cats you know you
heard about the thing we're Tyson he ran
out of gas
so he just gave the car to somebody and
went to like a dealership and bought a
Ferrari or so like it's just I mean I
mean listen I wouldn't do it to that
level but um yeah I mean I think you got
to enjoy your money but at the same time
you got to really be you know you got to
really be smart people don't live within
their within their means you know no
yeah and it's just that's why it had me
thinking them I was saying to you
recently I looked at your numbers on the
iTunes list I go dude you're on the
iTunes list you should be making you
could be making some decent money off of
this podcast yeah and I'm realizing it
from all these people I'm talking to and
and if you get the right sponsor like
you said a cigar if you get these
companies that you really actually
connect with like this guy was
explaining to me on the phone like uber
for instance he said that he started
experimenting any because he has like
he's bigger than all things comedy has a
lot of podcasts a lot of them and he's
explaining uber is starting to work with
him and how he's able to get free uber
cars for guests now any cost and he said
so he goes you send your guest and he
comes up to your house to do your
podcast in an uber Lincoln Town Car he's
going to talk about uber for [ __ ] 10
minutes and he's not even going to be
lying he's gonna say it was amazing i
was in the uber guy was hilarious I was
in this black town car it was amazing
it's like those are the best ads or when
it's just like it didn't sound like a
net yeah when you're passionate about
something it doesn't sound like an ad
like exactly like you just said if I'm
gonna talk about a cigar that I smoke
once a week because I love it and I
enjoy it when I get home and I unwind
and relax with it and it pairs amazing
with a bourbon or Scotch I don't even
have to sell that it's just that's what
I do you know what i mean so that those
you're right those are the sponsors and
i always said to anybody if you want to
be a sponsor on the verge effect I got a
kind of believe in it I got a kind of
believe in your service I got a kind of
talk about it with the passion as
opposed to just and I think that like
that comes across what listeners
listeners are like oh you know like it's
like when you're on stage doing stand-up
you can tell if a crowd is into
something and you're connecting or not
if you're talking about a product you
like you know it's it's and that those
are that that is and I you know anybody
I said somebody reached out to me the
other day about
um a ticket service like sporting event
tickets or like something like that like
a stub hub type thing like I like that
stuff like anybody like that so anybody
listening to my how many you have
sponsors right um I have one right now
but I mean they don't really pay me
money they just promote their product
and they they basically for everybody
that donates they send your buds to them
so it helps makes more ppl donate to my
podcast because they get a free pair of
earbuds and for my for my stand-up CDs
for their further forty dollar donation
well you know what some companies do too
i know i was talking to some comedian
that like smokes of vapor uses like the
vapor thing that you smoke and he
doesn't get paid from the company but
they just sent him a vapor like like
these felt like if you plug it little
send you like [ __ ] you know it's your to
your house or whatever that you know
they'll send you a product that you like
or believe in so like if you was gonna
talk all i bought this sony camera and
then like instead of sony giving you
money they'll just send you the camera
and to talk about yeah you know anything
do anything but you do gotta believe in
it you know well that's what they said
i'm i'm not going to say the name
because it like the number one podcast
out there right now my wife listens to
it and I don't need to promote it I
don't even want to say what it is but
they talk about that on the podcast
about how you can you shouldn't do a
commercial that isn't connected to you
or it's just it turns your it turns your
fans off it makes them not like you so
he makes it obvious when he's gonna do
it commercial he's like you're gonna
hear this song underneath it you know
it's a commercial he's like basically
says it and yeah excites no it's
definitely a turn off to do something
that you don't believe in or just to
make money and you people see it I know
somebody you're not gonna say his name
who has a podcast and he had a company
that when he first started now he's like
one of the biggest pop on the bridge job
it's not a bridge to burn this is a
positive it's a good move he was saying
the company so much and he came up with
this funny catchphrase when he would say
it on his podcast that not only did he
make a lot of money from the ads he owns
three percent of the company they gave
him a percentage of the company because
they knew this guy's podcast is so big
that if he's saying our company a lot
it's helping the company so why not give
him a piece he's making our company
worth more you know yes so much secret
money out there that you like that we
don't realize I think cuz we're creative
we miss it yeah well I need you know you
need a business guy that knows what
they're doing but like there might be
one of the worst in the history whoa you
what not knowing you're not here not
know like you're always like what I do
how do I do that and I always can tell
you're not gonna do I like you know what
I did though I I have been asking people
if you want to sponsor and people have
been reaching out to me and emailing me
that they want to but it does get to a
point where you need somebody um I was
talking to my you know my listeners and
I think what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
do a subscription thing where I'm gonna
add three extra episodes if you want
kind of the Nick DiPaolo style that's
what I think of as long as you keep one
for free no I've always told that I
don't ask for donation I don't do
anything like that you're always going
to get the wednesday night or thursday
morning one for free you're always going
to get that one for free but see but you
let me kind of let me cut you off you'll
be on the fence with that idea when you
realize that there could be more money
made if you were doing the advertising
the right way like you should one you
shouldn't be talking to the advertisers
yourself you should get a company yeah
that does that and they work with the
verzi effect podcast your numbers are
good enough trust me and then they they
take it you know usually it's they take
a high percentage but that's fine
because you don't have to do it and they
handle everything you get that and then
if you don't make it a subscription you
make you do four episodes a week and
they're all free and you're placing
those ads on all four of them your
money's gonna be more than if you were
charging that's it yeah people don't
realize ya know it's it's it's a whole
other it really is a whole other part of
it it's a whole other part of doing it
it's it's it starts off with hey I'm a
comic and I have a microphone and I'm
gonna do a podcast then all of a sudden
it's like you know I know people and I'm
not gonna mention names but I know a
handful of people that prob can live can
can live like not i mean i would never
not do i would always i would do
stand-up if I was making a million
dollars from my
I guess but there you know you can make
enough money to live now you know it's
really incredible man well there's
people instead it's the same with
stand-up ever when we started it was
just we wanted to get on stage we didn't
need money and then it became i need
twenty-five bucks and then you know 28
years later I'm like this [ __ ]
only once give me a hundred bucks yes
for a sellout and he's giving me this
much for the for the show and I'm like
bitching about it so it's just the way
it works we've come full circle sourcing
you see you wrote you wrote for the UH
you wrote for the gay guy or whatever a
gay guy hey what are your hobbies I
don't know blowing Brendan under the
gymnasium up Jesus uh so all right so
you run it you wrote for the roast and
you're gonna go to ridgefield playhouse
and hopefully make another hundred bucks
yes and then the the big show on
februari 13r it's the we haven't we
haven't forgot joe Matarese calm for the
South Jersey tickets South Jersey
februari 13th the wrist Ritz theater joe
Matarese will be there it's his neck of
the woods don't miss it I won't talk
about money either i noticed that it
gets really unfunny when i start talking
about finances now you know but you get
you going through your faces and i
remember your first phase was the real
estate face and then and now it's the
money phase but always great talking to
you Joe this has been the verzi effect
episode 2 43 with special guest comedian
joe Matarese this is going to be on just
one part so this will be part 2 and I'm
gonna put both out today so this will be
out thank you for having me um so those
two things you want those are the own
things you wanna plug and your website
Joe it's joe Matarese com yeah and my
podcast is fixing Joe take a listen yeah
it's got a good podcasts and matter ease
if you don't know is Mata are esee uh
always good to talk to you my friend
have a good time tell Artie Lange I said
what's up and I'll talk to you soon
alright later buddy all right